the first wizard King was lemiel Silva
million a user of light magic and the
legendary hero who defeated the giant
demon near Hage Village the 11th wizard
King was princeia funny bunny the only
known female wizard king and the proud
owner of the cringiest last name in the
series she possessed Legion magic which
allowed her to create an army of magical
Soldiers the 16th wizard King was Jester
garandros a user of incredibly powerful
barrier magic that could create
virtually indestructible force fields
around large areas the 20th wizard King
was Edward avalace who used ice wedge
magic to create and manipulate massive
amounts of jagged ice the 27th wizard
King was Conrad Leto who used the
uniquely powerful and versatile key
magic the 28th and current wizard King
is Julius novacrono who uses time magic
among others